we have reporters
we have reporters in the white house
asking the administration jinsaki
to guarantee that christmas presents are
going to be delivered what the [ __ ]
this is this is what they're asking i'm
i'm dead serious this happened today
they're asking the administration to
guarantee
that christmas presents are delivered by
christmas this is the [ __ ] that we gotta
[ __ ] deal with this is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is the questions that they
[ __ ] ask let me show you the clip
we can go ahead let me ask that a
slightly similar but different way sure
based on everything being announced
today yeah
can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee what we can do
is use every lever at the federal
government disposal to reduce uh delays
to ensure that we are
addressing bottlenecks in the system
including uh ports and the the need for
them to be open longer hours so that
goods can arrive
and we can continue to press uh not only
uh workers and unions but also companies
to take as many steps as they can to
reduce these delays
so there you have it
uh
we seriously are living in a
a reality of where we're at the
intersection of wrestlemania in real
life because these are the questions
that have to be asked if the
administration is going to guarantee
that people are going to get their
[ __ ] christmas packages and here's
what this is
here's this is all distraction politics
and they're starting to roll this ball
down the hill this is all right-wing
[ __ ] that is jimmying up this conference
conversation
of christmas packages being on time and
the administration guaranteeing them as
if it's going to be joe biden's fault
that christmas dis gifts didn't get to
your under your christmas tree in time
maybe you'll put on a red suit and get
in a sleigh with his tiny little
reindeer and go deliver him himself you
people are out of your [ __ ] minds
you've lost it
this is not
oh [ __ ]
you're gonna make the administration
stand and guarantee that christmas
packages are gonna be delivered because
here's what this is
this is the right wing rolling this ball
down the hill of oh cancel culture on
christmas you're going to cancel
christmas war on christmas you're going
to see it on fox news ah they're not
going to let your these ships are all
sea and they're holding these ships off
sea so they can cancel christmas and
there's a war on christmas joe biden
doesn't want there to be christmas you
people are [ __ ] stupid it's not even
halloween yet
if you want your christmas presents to
be on time go buy them now
if you if if you don't and here's here's
how i know here's how i know this is a
right wing thing it's because they're
they're making it about christmas
they're not
they're not saying like what's gonna
happen if people can't eat during
christmas what happens during the
holidays we still have thousands and
thousands of people in the hospital with
covid are people getting sick because of
covid how are we gonna
are those families are what are those
families gonna do what are we gonna do
if people can't afford to to
give themselves a christmas meal or a
holiday meal what are we going to do
nope it's about the [ __ ] gifts
it's about the prisons
that's how i know it's a right wing [ __ ]
because that's what they concentrate on
that's the whole [ __ ] thing i mean
jesus christ they run around oh my god i
can't i can't go to work because i ain't
got a vaccine i can't get on an airplane
i can't go into concert yeah that's your
choice it's your choice you're making a
choice not to get vaccinated so you
can't do that kind of [ __ ]
and they don't understand they don't
understand actual real choice in this
country they think their choices are
they have 33 choices of flavors at
baskin robbins that's their that's their
idea of choices and liberty and freedom
that they can go to the grocery store
and there's oh god there's there's 50
different frozen pizzas woohoo freedom
freedom liberty and rights
that's not that's not freedom or liberty
to choose
tony's pizza
it's a good brand
i don't know if it has to do with the
name or not
but to choose tony's maybe red barons i
don't know
to choose those over any other because
you got the liberty to choose what
frozen pizza you want
that is not your actual choices that's
not it that's not liberty that's that's
not it
that's not that's not it
it's not your liberty to receive
christmas gifts at a certain day and
time
maybe a certain amount of planning will
get you there
but the administration and the federal
government cannot guarantee that you're
gonna get a certain gift on a certain
day
what the [ __ ] and really honestly if you
people are so [ __ ] worried about
packages getting delivered maybe you
should go with the united states postal
service and question dejoy and figure
out why he's not de-fired yet
or arrested
and de jail
maybe maybe that's who you should ask
the questions to
is the [ __ ] government
the part of the government that delivers
packages
not
not the white house if they're gonna
guarantee
get the [ __ ] out of here
this is this this and this kind of stuff
this nonsense this war on christmas [ __ ]
that they're gonna do this is what
they're gonna do
i i already know it i i can already tell
we're not even halloween yet and they're
starting this war on christmas joe
biden's gonna cancel christmas [ __ ]
with this they're not gonna guaran he's
not gonna guarantee they're gonna be on
foxes tonight
did you hear ginsak he's not gonna
guarantee that your christmas gifts are
gonna be delivered tucker carlson cue it
up
cue up the [ __ ] clip it's gonna be
there
it's a war on christmas they won't
guarantee your christmas packages are
delivered
it's already gonna happen tonight it'll
start to happen
they're gonna start rolling this ball
down the hill that joe biden is the
grinch
and it's to distract
from the trump organization being in so
much trouble and the select committee
laying down the hammer
if you haven't heard this news the trump
organization is in serious financial
trouble
they're trying to sell the lease to the
the dc hotel the trump hotel in dc you
know the one he laundered money through
the entire time he was president
now he has to sell the son of a [ __ ]
for like i don't know 370 390 million
dollars he not the hotel he doesn't own
the [ __ ] building that's what
everyone doesn't get about this
[ __ ] he doesn't own that
building the federal government owns
that building he just leases it to put
his name on it that's it
he just leased the building from the
federal government
which you know in the emoluments clause
we should really [ __ ] cut that [ __ ]
out
we should really hammer him on how he
launder money through the dc hotel and
maybe that'll end up in a federal court
somewhere who knows civil or criminal
but they want to sell it now now that
he's not president
and it's not easy for him to trade
favors for people who go to the dc hotel
i'm just assuming
you know launder money through that
thing possibly
now he wants to get rid of it it
couldn't be that it lost 70 million
dollars i'm sure that's not it
i'm sure that they didn't rob the money
out of it like he robbed his casinos
back in the late 80s early 90s
because he's a shitty business person
listen
he played a business person on tv he's
not actually one
and it's more clear now than ever when
they have to sell the lease to the dc
hotel because they laundered all the
money out of it
it's losing millions
the other trouble that the trump
organization in it appears is with the
inauguration committee
and where all that [ __ ] money went it
appears that ivanka trump somehow stuffs
money in her pocket and the trump
organization's pocket i wonder i wonder
if the manhattan da's
investigation has anything to do with
alan weisselberg and the trump
organization funneling inauguration
money into the trump org
and where it went to i wonder if that
has anything to do with it you know we
heard that we were supposed to have some
more indictments maybe just maybe we're
here hear the words inaugural committee
because there's another federal
indictment that has to do with the 2016
campaign and another indictment that
possibly has that looks like it could do
with the inaugural committee the tom
barrett case the tom barrett indictment
he was he was part of the inaugural
committee he was taking foreign money
for something else but it appears that
there was a relationship there it's kind
of funny how the the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa's poopy pants his first trip
was just to the saudis
that was his first foreign trip
and maybe maybe just maybe it was a
favor kind of like the favor that was
given when jesse benton took a hundred
thousand dollars and funneled russian
money into the 2016 trump campaign
and now he's under in federal indictment
for [ __ ] for for funneling illegal
foreign money
to make sure that a russian got a
meeting with trump in a campaign
fundraiser
these things all seem familiar
i'm not sure what one thing that is in
common with all these things but it
seems like there's one thing or one fat
slob
that is in common with all these [ __ ]
things
which makes me believe that the trump
organization is going down like a fresh
cut tree
not to mention
not to mention
we have the select committee
and we'll get to that
about the us marshals meadows patel
scovino
and bannon here in a second but there's
one other thing about the trump
organization that a lot of people are
really worried about and that is uh crew
brought it up the group crew is
campaigning to get all the federal
contracts canceled
because of their criminal indictment the
trump organization is under criminal
indictment in new york state it is not
civil indictment
they are not being investigated they are
criminally charged
are you [ __ ] people paying attention
the guy who thinks he's gonna run for
the president in 2024 on the republican
the gqp ticket
the company that he's owned and ran for
decades and decades and decades and
laundered money and probably going to
get charged with more tax fraud and more
people are going to be brought into this
indictment with the manhattan d.a in the
state of new york
is under criminal indictment
they're being accused of crimes
you got it
the former president of the united
states
the mango mussolini jesus
the gqp front brother of the
2024 presidential campaign who continues
to go rally because he's irrelevant
because he can't manage to conjure up
any kind of following without a rally
without his minions
all all of his concert
groupies coming and standing behind him
the same [ __ ] people it's the same
[ __ ] people have you watched this you
go to the rallies you look at the videos
it's the same [ __ ] behind him
it's the same they just they just kind
of shuffle them around it's the same
[ __ ]
that are behind that some [ __ ]
the same [ __ ] people in the crowd
same exact people
it's like you know 2 000 people same
[ __ ]
same [ __ ] all going to the same
spot and they gather up a few local
groupies but it's all the same groupies
going to one spot same of others
but the trump organization
the business that the the former
president and his children
which his children were part of the
government
they were part of the trump
administration
that company is under criminal
indictment as well as its cfo its chief
financial officer alan weisselberg
and it seems it seems as if there's
trump inaugural money missing
hmm
and it seems as if it was funneled
through the trump organization who's
criminally indicted
and it seems as if
with two indictments with
barrick
tom barrack and the jesse benton diamond
it really seems like those have to do
with the trump campaign
it's not hard to follow the [ __ ]
bouncing ball here
it really is not difficult
now we are counting on the department of
justice and merrick garland to do their
jobs but it's gonna take some time
because the one thing that the select
committee
and even the prosecutors are worried
about is the trump chaos machine because
he's continuing to stoke chaos
continuing continuing to snow chaos and
then they're stoking chaos with vaccine
mandates and mask mandates and
they keep on with this stuff i mean even
jim jordan is is talking about how they
they need to ban all mandate vaccine
mandates in ohio polio and all of them
for everyone what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
and the reason why they're getting there
they're starting to evolve from
covet vaccine bad to all vaccines are
bad is because it is the evidence is
going to bear out that vaccine mandates
work and when you do vaccine mandates
people get vaccinated and when people
get vaccinated we won't have the problem
that we have with covid and when the
pandemic is over they don't have this
wedge issue why do you think they want
to continue the pandemic they want to
continue it as a wedge issue because
they want trumpism fascism in a manga
hat to continue and the only way to do
that is to divide up america and the
easiest way to divide up america right
now is old big bad scary government you
know in the form of private companies
developing vaccines to help you save
your life from a deadly pathogen that we
all know about now you know that thing
where private companies are actually
doing it and the government's
encouraging it and matter of fact
they'll even pay for it for you to get
it because they don't want you to get
sick and spend all kinds of money on
health care because that's what the
federal federal government is doing
without you doing it and the economy's
suffering you know that type of [ __ ]
yeah okay
they want the pandemic to continue so
the plan is is to continue this road
down vaccine mandates all of them are
bad
because
they're they're up against a wall here
of the vaccine mandate because people
are starting to
get their job they're starting to lose
their [ __ ] job starting to lose their
positions
and they're up against these vaccine
mandates and republicans know they work
it's
historical data proves it out
they work they work they work they've
always worked to continue to work and
they're going to continue to work my
disappointment is is that we didn't do
this [ __ ] sooner we should have done it
six months ago [ __ ] these [ __ ]
[ __ ] them
you don't want to get vaccinated fine
stay the [ __ ] at home you don't get to
have a job you don't get to get on an
airplane you don't get on a bus you
don't get on a train fine [ __ ] you you
don't get to do anything the rest of us
did that [ __ ] all all 20 20 and you
[ __ ] did whatever the [ __ ] you
wanted to do and you spread around covid
you [ __ ] killed hundreds of thousands
of people and you continue to kill 100
thousands of people
because you're [ __ ] selfish because
that's who you are that's who you are
conservatives fascists in this country
are [ __ ] selfish evangelicals
self-proclaimed christians are [ __ ]
selfish they don't believe a single word
that [ __ ] book says not a [ __ ]
word never have never will